we have a ton of news that is breaking
we begin with this Fox News Alert a
grisly case that has riveted the entire
country and horrified Americans
everywhere and that is Alex murdaugh
found guilty on all charges including
two counts of murder with a weapon uh
and tonight by the way we'll cover every
aspect of this case you're going to hear
from the prosecutors legal experts other
people on the ground and by the way of
all people guess who's spoken out O.J
Simpson even waited on I know on this
case uh we're going to play his comments
Straight Ahead tonight but first let me
give you some background for those of
you who work for a living and not able
to follow this during the day this
became a fascinating case and a lot of
twists and turns and a lot of people
speculating he might get off the jury
came back in less than three hours now
Alex Murdock is the prominent South
Carolina attorney Big Time Democratic
donor is now facing life in prison for
murdering his wife Maggie his 22 year
old son it took the jury three hours to
deliver this verdict but this twisted
and very gruesome and horrible double
homicide it will haunt people in this
country especially in South Carolina now
in the low country for decades to come
now until recently the murders were a
prominent family in Hampton County they
ran what was the biggest Law Firm they
had deep deep ties to the local judicial
system from judges to prosecutors to
police the murders were among the most
wealthy and well-connected families in
the region but at times they seem to
believe they themselves were Above the
Law Alex murdaugh had a very expensive
drug habit over the past several years
Murdoch was burning through millions of
dollars on pills and God knows what else
in order to pay for all of this is
lifestyle and his drug use well he
robbed clients he robbed friends he
guzzled money from his own law firm and
committed insurance fraud on a massive
scale Alex also faced mounting legal
bills related to his son's boating
accident that looks like maybe they
tried to cover up we'll tell you about
that in 2019 Paul Murdock drunkenly
drove the family boat into a bridge it
killed a young girl a passenger on board
Alex Murdoch was facing financial and
legal ruin apparently this all came to a
head on the evening of June 7 2021 when
Alex shot his wife uh four to five times
with a rifle and then shot his own son
twice with a shotgun at the family's
hunting compound and his hun his son's
head was all but missing from the blast
now that night Alex Murdoch called 9-1-1
he told the police that he happened upon
the dead bodies and had no idea who
killed his wife and son a few months
later in sept September of 2021 Alex
murdaugh attempted to Stage his own
murder paying his drug dealer to shoot
him in the head in what was what a
possible botched attempt to commit
insurance fraud now following that
incident murdaugh was finally charged
with killing his wife and his son now it
was interesting they didn't have the
cell phone records in the beginning but
cell phone records and high velocity
blood spatter on Murdoch's clothes
placed him at the scene of the crime he
was on tape telling the police he wasn't
there in the quote kennel I'll get into
more detail in a minute but that did not
stop Murdoch from taking the stand and
to offer a very dramatic defense here's
part of it take a look where did you
touch Maggie
I think I touched her down
I was around like
the
I don't know I don't know if you if you
ask me exactly I think I touched her
down around her waist but I don't know
it was so bad
excuse me
the jury they didn't buy it and now Alex
murdaugh will spend the rest of his life
behind bars now here is the lead
prosecutor reacting to this verdict
let's take a look
Justice was done today
it doesn't matter who your family is it
doesn't matter how much money you have
or people think you have it doesn't
matter what
you think how prominent you are if you
do wrong if you break the law if you
murder
then Justice will be done in South
Carolina and I think South Carolina has
shown the nation in the world how a
process can work and work well hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else